were trying to aim for 300K in the next
couple of months I'm a lot smaller than
some of the bigger channels but
nonetheless we have a great Community
going and you know every every sub
counts
[Music]
we are going to play E5
which is the opening that I've been
playing most commonly on the speedrun
this fourth speedrun has been all about
playing classical openings
and essentially taking care of the
fundamentals so we're facing the move
Knight C3 which is the Vienna
and we're going to respond with the
traditional Knight F6
this is very much still Theory here the
Vienna Gambit is F4 okay we're facing
the Vienna Gambit
uh which has become a lot more popular
in recent years because of Levy's course
and because of just a ton of content
creators and top players have been
recommending this I have a couple of
students who play the Vienna it's
totally legit it's a good opening for 15
1600 level and if you're an E5 player
with black you absolutely need to know
how to respond to the Vienna most people
a lot of people are already confused in
this position what they're confused by
is that they think that this is
basically a king's Gambit the difference
between the Vienna and a king's gamut is
that there are these two knights on C3
and F6 what does that mean that means
accepting the Vienna is a terrible idea
because black white pushes the pawn up
to E5 chasing the Knight away from F6
and the Knight has to undevelop itself
on G8 so as most of you should know
black has only one move in this position
that leads to a feasible position and
that is to counter strike in the center
with D5
this move makes conceptual sense because
white has spent a couple of moves in the
opening pushing their pawns especially
making the king a little bit more
vulnerable and the classic rule
basically says that if your opponent is
pushing a lot of Pawns on the flank or
on the side of the board you want to
counter strike in the center and that's
exactly what we're doing D5 F takes C5
and Knight takes C4 is very common
theory and here there are two moves
yeah Knight F3 is the is the old move
this is the old move and it's a lot less
common these days than Queen F3 which is
what Levy recommends in his course
Knight F3 is what people used to play
and it's a completely reasonable move
there's nothing terribly wrong with it
and you need to know how to respond to
it if you are an E5 player black has
several things that they can do
well obviously we should make a
developing move and we should keep this
Knight on e4 we shouldn't trade on C3
unless we have to
one good option
is to develop this bishop to C5 and that
is the move we are going to make what
does this move do well what it does is
pretty obvious we are threatening a fork
with the Knight on F2 we're defending
the F2 Square now you might look at this
and say wait a second I think this is a
really dumb move because you're walking
right into the move d4 you're allowing
white to occupy the center with Tempo
and chase this bishop away but there's a
catch because the move d4 has a serious
drawback it exposes the A5 E1 diagonal
which means we can now park our Bishop
on B4 violating an opening rule which
says that you should only move a piece
once in the opening but this is an
extenuating circumstance because white
has given us the license to do this by
pushing a bunch of Pawns so fast
development isn't as important here as
high quality development so by playing
Bishop E4 what are we doing we're
putting pressure on the knight from two
different sources we are threatening to
play Knight takes C3 followed by Bishop
takes C3 that would Fork the king in The
Rook
and we're forcing white to defend the
night
white does not have any great ways to
defend the Knight
you might say but isn't Bishop D2 just a
natural and good move Bishop D2 is the
best move
but then we can take that Bishop with
our Knight we'll have a bishop pair and
we'll be able to continue putting
pressure on White Center by pushing the
C Pawn up to C5
so to my knowledge this is the best way
to equalize against the Knight F3 Vienna
now we eliminate this nice little Bishop
Queen takes D2
and now we need to decide how we're
going to continue our development
so again
there is
a couple of different things that black
can do here all of it is feasible we can
continue our development
uh by playing a move like Bishop G4
we can also put this bishop on E6 which
is a somewhat more conservative way of
developing but also perfectly solid
and of course we can push the pawn up to
C5 and put pressure on White's D4 Pawn
we could have also played C5 on the
previous move maybe that was even
stronger
so let me think how I want us to play
right now I want us to play a little bit
more solidly conservatively because
that's been the sort of Zen of the
speedrun I'm trying to play in a style
that's very solid a lot of you are
proposing Bishop F5 the reason I like
Bishop F5 less is because white can then
develop the bishop to D3 and you might
say well great then that leads to a
trade but I don't want us to trade the
light squared Bishop because we have the
bishop pair we have two Bishops white
only has one that's called the bishop
pair and it's considered an asset in
most types of positions and this is no
exception I want us to keep both of our
Bishops and so for the light squid
Bishop the best Prospect is to develop
it to E6 or to put it on G4 which is a
somewhat more
aggressive developing Square Let's Play
Bishop E6 let's remain solid and
complete our development in relatively
quiet fashion
don't forget that C5 is still very much
a a possible move a little bit down the
line okay so where should our Bishop go
I think most people would be tempted to
drop it back to A5 in order to keep the
pin against the Knight
in my experience that is an inaccuracy
the reason is that after Bishop A5 white
can push the beep on up to B4 well big
whoop then we can move the bishop back
to B6 but once the bishop sits on B6 it
is surrounded by White's pawns and
crucially
what move who can tell me what move is
so much harder to play when White's Pawn
sits on B4
which critical idea that I've already
mentioned is integral part of Black's
eventual strategy yeah C5 right it's
virtually impossible to play C5 and so
we should drop our Bishop back to E7 now
you might be scratching your beard here
and saying but can't white play B4
anyway yes white can play B4 anyway but
now this move no longer comes with Tempo
which means it no longer carries a
threat
what why is that important because we
can try then to undermine the pawn on B4
using our own pawns and to undermine
essentially means to use your pawns to
force an opponent's Pawn out of a
particular Square we had the classic
move A7 A5
okay let's continue our development we
should Castle we should definitely
castle and I think our opponent is going
to do the same
I think our opponent is going to do the
same
and now we have a major choice
we can definitely play C5 you know I've
just been mentioning I've been singing
the Praises of this move but we don't
have to play C5 we can also play this
position without C5
and we can Orient ourselves toward
another Pawn break that most of you are
going to be very reluctant to play what
is this other Pawn break that you could
try to carry out not on this move but I
think maybe even on the next move it's
F6 why am I even thinking about playing
F6 well it's because White's strongest
Pawn is E5 E5 is hanging over us like
the Sword of Damocles it's sort of how
do I like to phrase these things the
plot on E5 is sort of interfering with
uh the communication of blacks pieces
between the two flanks right it's
controlling a couple of squares it's
clamping down on us the pawn on E5 is
clamping down on us so what is the best
way of preparing the move F6 well
presumably it's to bring another piece
it's to develop this Knight because we
haven't completed our development where
should we develop it to
well we shouldn't develop it to C6
because it blocks the C Pawn I still
want us to reserve the right to play C5
we need to be as flexible as possible in
these positions
but the second reason we want to prepare
is because we want to prepare F6 and the
Knight obviously controls the F6 Square
from D7
uh you might say well doesn't this
weaken the pawn on D5 it does
but white has no way of actually
attacking that pawn even one more time
and even if they do we can defend it
with a move C6 we can build up a little
Pawn chain if necessary so we shouldn't
be worried about the pawn on D5
okay so hopefully those who are new to
this Peter and are getting a good sense
of
what the Speedrome looks like this is
how most games look like I'm talking a
ton maybe too much but I'm trying to
explain the heck out of every move that
I make
Knight T1
I assume our opponent is trying to bring
the Knight around to E3 which is a
perfectly reasonable idea
but I don't think it prevents us from
playing F6 I think now is a perfect
opportunity to push the pawn up to F6
and try to undermine the pawn on E5
leading to a trade and maybe get the
Knight around to E4
does white have to take on F6 no
obviously not
but if white does not take on F6
then we are going to take on E5
what's the big deal white can recapture
but that pod on E5 is going to become
isolated right it's no longer going to
have the support of the D4 Pawn because
the D4 Pawn becomes the E5 pawn and then
I'll show you after the game how we
would go about attacking the pawn on E5
if White had not recaptured on F6 or
captured I suppose what should we take
back with
well the two candidate was I think Rook
takes F6 is pretty awkward so our two
candidate moves our Knight takes F6 and
Bishop takes F6 Knight takes F6 has an
upside and a downside the upside of
Knight takes F6 is that the Knight can
head for E4 and E4 is a nice centralized
Square the downside of Knight takes F6
is that it allows the potentially
unpleasant move Knight G5
how dangerous is Knight G5 well it's not
very dangerous because if Knight G5 we
can drop our Bishop back to D7 and how
can we follow up in that position well
we can push our Pawn to H6 and try to
chase the Knight out of G5
um but the plus side of taking with the
bishop is that we're we're restricting
we're restricting the Knight on F3 and
the downside of taking with the bishop
is that the Knight on D7 is like hey
what about me where are you going to put
me oh we can keep the Knight on D7 but
that's a pretty passive Square
I think that Knight takes F6 is the most
sort of ambitious is the wrong word but
I think it's the clearest path to a good
position
uh because you should always be trying
to find the best squares for your pieces
and you shouldn't be afraid of Moves
Like Knight G5 a lot of players in the
like 12 1300 level
they're they're really afraid of what I
call one moveitis one moveitis is uh the
sort of condition of making a move just
because it carries a one move threat
right and moves are not made good just
because they carry a threat a lot of
good moves do carry a threat but you
should always you should never be afraid
of a move simply because it carries a
threat
um after Knight G5 we could just drop
our Bishop back to D7 and Chase the
Knight away with H6 okay Knight F2
Knight F2
and by the way I'll answer questions
after the game so if you have
uncertainties or points of confusion
please be patient I will talk about all
of them after the game okay Knight F2 is
a great move our opponent is playing
well
the position is fairly balanced and in
these types of boring same Pawn
structure positions the best strategy is
to identify pieces that can be improved
can we put our pieces on better squares
well the answer is yes what pieces am I
looking at well one piece I'm looking at
is this bishop on E7 I think we can
reposition it to D6
everybody should see that this is a
better Square it's controlling more
squares it's also controlling the five
square it's discouraging white from
putting a knight on E5
and it's kind of clearing the E file so
that later on we can put a rook on E8
and that Rook or maybe the other Rook on
E8 and that Rook is going to control
more Square so Bishop D6 is one of those
one of those normal moves that you
should be in the habit of making
these types of positions white does the
same Bishop D3
yeah our opponent I have to say is
playing very very well so I don't think
that black is better here I think the
position is equal
all right well how's it how do we
continue
well I think we should continue by
coordinating our Rooks
one pretty straightforward move that
comes to my mind
is Queen D7 and then bringing the Rook
to E8 and putting everything in the
center
um we can also play the move C7 C6 and
try to put the queen on C7 but the
problem with C6 is that white brings The
Rook over to E1 and attacks our Bishop
and the upside of having a queen on D7
is that it defends the bishop on E6 or
Rook a E1 no longer comes with the
threat we can safely bring our own Rook
to E8
well C5 I have soured on the Move C5
because in the worst case scenario why
can meet C5 with C3
protecting the pawn on D4 and who really
benefits from that Queen side tension I
don't know if it's black I don't know if
C5 uh is all that dangerous anymore Rook
A1 played we're gonna do the same we're
gonna bring a rook to E8 and yeah
position is totally equal I think
uh I have to give a lot of credit to our
opponent he's playing
incredibly well so far but this is where
a lot of players in the 1700 rating
range tend to make mistakes like you've
made a lot of the obvious moves but will
he be able to find ways to keep the
tension without you know making any
obvious weakening moves
do we have a long-term plan here
um
not really but you don't need one I
think plans are overrated C3
another good move I think we're going to
do the same we're going to play C6
yeah what is the purpose of C6 it's to
protect the pawn on T5 just making a
general improving move also we open up
the C7 Square for our Queen so in the
event of 95 we don't actually have to
take the Knight anymore we can drop our
Queen to the right
yeah the thing about such positions with
an open Center is that it is hard to
come up with a plan and we don't need to
right now we're in the phase of the game
where both of us are improving our
pieces
and at some point we're going to have a
confrontation right this is not going to
go on forever and the question is going
to be who has positioned their pieces
better when
you know the the confrontation happens
when tactics start to appear on the
board and maybe a knight appears on E5
so we'll see all right so far
our opponent is not playing any worse
than me I mean he's playing at a solid
Master Level
so far obviously white is playing very
well Bishop C2 is another great move
Bishop C2 is another great move
uh dropping the bishop back and maybe
Paving the way for Knight D3
okay so what do I want to do here
well what is the White's strongest piece
it's not that easy to say what White's
strongest piece is uh but one of the
Annoying pieces is this bishop on C2
it's controlling a lot of light squares
our Bishop is definitely worse than
White's Bishop that should be pretty
obvious to just visually just visually
so what move comes to mind
what move comes to mind right on the
topic of exchanging worst pieces for
your opponent's better pieces Let's Play
Bishop F5
this also starts kind of a direct
confrontation because now the Rooks are
staring at each other and now we're
starting to get tactics now this could
fizzle out into a bunch of Trades and
maybe this game will end in a quick draw
or this could start to get a little bit
spicier precisely because we now have
what I like to refer to as tension I use
this word very often tension essentially
stems from pieces that are staring at
each other and the potential for trades
that builds tactical tension and it
creates fertile ground for you know
deflection tactics and other types of
tactics that stem from confrontations
between pieces
okay so what am I expecting Rook takes
CA yeah I was going to say so obviously
we take back with the Rook I'm not even
commenting on that
uh what else are we gonna take back with
the Knight right the queen just blunders
the bishop so we just don't have a
choice here and this is going to be a
tough position for me to win because
look how symmetrical the pawn structure
is and with the E file being open rookie
one could basically Exchange
all of the heavy pieces and there is a
high probability that we're going to get
some sort of an end game here that I'm
gonna have to try to squeeze
but a lot of you might be looking at
this and saying what a boring position
this is boring these are the types of
positions that you have to know how to
play if you want to get good you have to
know how to play boring positions
without doing anything dumb
and you have to develop the skill of
squeezing out advantages in equal
positions that's just inevitable
and I think a lot of people have this
dismissive attitude where
you know they're looking at a boring
position ah like I don't really want to
learn about this
uh you know if you want to be a
well-rounded player that's not the right
approach
okay
so rookie one uh
gives us a decision what is the decision
well the decision is whether we should
take the rokani one and trade pieces
what are the other options we can also
decline the trade we can play Rook if we
want to keep the Rooks on the board we
can play Rook Cafe what is the
positional drawback who can tell me
of the Mover Cafe
what is the drawback of declining the
trade here
it gives up the file right it gives up
the open file although you could argue
that The Rook on f8 does control another
open file the f file is an open file
just because there's minor pieces on it
doesn't mean the file isn't open an open
file means there are no pawns on it
but there is the third option here that
kind of appeals to me
yeah we can block with the Knight we can
block with the Knight we can play the
interesting move Knight to E4
which leads to a lot of tactical tension
if Knight takes E4 then we take back
with a pawn and we're chilling
what bothers me about Knight E4 is the
possibility of Queen to D3
and queen to D3 is a scary move because
the Rook on E8 is going to be undefended
so the Knight cannot move let alone the
fact that we're gonna lose our Queen
but I have a couple of interesting ideas
and I think we're going to take the risk
and I think we're going to take the risk
we're going to play 94.
because in the resulting position I've
done some calculation and I think that
there's a high probability of white
making a blunder
so we're going to go 94.
now if Knight takes E4 then we take back
with a pawn we're threatening the Knight
although technically we're not
threatening the night in that position
Queen D3 is on the board
so let me show you the move that I came
up with the move that I came up with is
Rook to E6 and hopefully
hopefully this move leads to a mistake
by white
hopefully this move leads to a mistake
by white
pause champ
I'm gonna be silent for a bit and
I'm gonna let people on Twitch and on
YouTube just understand what what makes
rookie 6 an annoying move for white
there is some Venom to this move that's
all I'm gonna say there is some serious
Venom to this move
serious Venom to this move
but so far our opponent has been
unflagging
literally and figuratively
and that's a blunder
and we have a beautiful tactic here you
guys or wait no this is not a blender
maybe it's a blunt or one second I think
I spoke too soon
we have a beautiful idea here but it
doesn't quite work hmm
I I miss the detail one second let me
let me calculate
oh
my God this is actually really cool I
think it works I think it works guys
there's a a gorgeous tactic here
or does it
um I'm still calculating
I'm still calculating just a second
no might not work
sag
false advertising I missed the detail
there
let's see if we can set it up though
yeah Bishop takes H2 is what I had in
mind now you guys see it Bishop takes H2
is what I had in mind after King H2 Rook
H6 check King G1 and I thought we had
Rook H1 King takes H1 Knight takes F2
Forks the king and queen but
unfortunately there's a knight on F2
that's guarding the H1 Square
so now I'm trying to set it up
it doesn't quite work
sorry about that I I it was an honest
mistake
oh so then C4 is a really good move
man
this guy's strong so what should we do
instead
well we can play the move G5 that's a
little bit drastic but G5 has the idea
of playing G4
um so that's interesting
trying to set this tactic up and I can't
find a way to do it
I can't quite find a way to set up this
tactic
hmm
can he push C5 yeah no I mean
Rook H6 the problem with the Rook H6 is
that there's Knight takes E4
okay I think we're gonna go for G5 as as
risky as this move is
it seems to me
that G5 might be the best chance to to
bloody the what to like you know muddy
the water sorry bloody the waters
that the Expressions muddy the waters
so what are we doing with G5 who can
explain well nobody needs to explain
it's obvious we're trying to push the
pawn up to G4
we're trying to push the pawn up to G4
and what is good about pushing the pawn
up to G4 well the diet on F3 is
paralyzed because if white moves it then
the Knight on F2 will be lost
oh there's some there's some amazing
like ideas but they don't quite work
they don't quite work okay G4 let's go
G4 it is our opponent has not stopped us
from advancing the pawn up to G4 this is
setting up a lot of beautiful ideas
buckle your Steeples nobody go anywhere
this is going to be cool
this is going to be cool
what's the idea after Knight H4 you'll
see
I will keep sign I will stay mom on it
but you'll see what the idea is
start calculating in the meantime if you
really want to be proactive
you know this is where I mean if you're
watching this from YouTube you should
pause the video
and you know if you want to really learn
from you should set it up on a board and
start analyzing but that's not what most
people do
this is where you have to realize that
White's King is now in very serious
trouble it is not well protected and
that leads me to believe that tactics
there's a ground is for itself for
tactics and as it turns out there's a
very simple tactic here that doesn't
actually win the game on the spot but I
think it comes very very close what is
this tactic does anybody see it it's not
Knight takes F2 that blunders a queen
that blunters a queen
the move G3 is very tempting but it also
doesn't achieve the desired effect
although after hg3 you have the cool
idea Knight takes G3 I'll show that
after the game but as everybody's
spotting Bishop takes H2 is indeed the
move
very simple clearance combination
uh this is this is pretty standard I
mean most of you should have seen this
move pretty far pretty fast
what are we doing we're forcing the king
onto H2 and then we're forking
forking the king and Knight with G3 now
there is a gorgeous idea here that I'll
show after the game there's a gorgeous
idea that leads to A better ending for
Black but I think we're not gonna play
it because G3 leads to a winning
position as much as I want to play that
other move
I'm pretty positive the G3 just ends the
game so we have to be objective
we have to be objective and we're going
to play the move G3
and I'll show you the idea after the
game
yeah sag exactly
they said it 10 other times yeah but
that always happens you see an idea in
10 different positions you guys will be
able to relate to this you see the right
idea in like five different positions
but precisely at the moment when you
should have played it that's when you
missed it what do we do now
okay well perhaps some of you are
attracted by Queen takes F2 check very
tempting move but it doesn't work Rook
takes F2 G takes F2 simply King F1 and
there's no follow-up
but the simplest is just GF yeah GF
check King F1 and Rook H6 ends the game
notice that if a rook appears on H1 that
is indeed Checkmate how do we get a rook
to H1 well we play Rook H6 right easy
Rook lift and the greatest thing is that
white can do absolutely nothing about it
note that the F2 Pawn is defended two
different ways so Knight takes E4 does
not help white Rook H1 is made in one
okay Rook takes C4 doesn't help
Queen H3 blunders the queen queen G3
blunder is the queen and here we're not
even taking the Rook we're playing Rook
H1 and rookie one is checkmate
uh on the next move easy
on the attack did turn out to be
somewhat anti-climactic but that's all
what happens very often
uh and there was a lot that was hidden
behind the surface
so a lot to talk about so this is indeed
the Vienna defense uh the Vienna game
Sorry
uh D5 is very important
uh D6 is what a lot of people default to
when they don't know what to do D6 is a
decent move but it's I mean obviously
black is worse like it's very very
passive and you don't want to go D6
there's a couple of funny lines where
black plays e takes F4 white plays E5
the Knight has to go back to G8 which is
terrible
now white brings the Knight out to F3 if
you're learning the Vienna for white
very common mistake folks is to play D4
in this position
the reason it's bad is because black has
a check on H4
and the reason the check on H4 is
dangerous is because the pawn on F4
prevents white from pushing G3 which you
have to move your king out is this the
end of the game that no obviously not
but you want to avoid this if possible
and it's possible to avoid this by
starting with Knight F3 don't forget to
play Knight F3 first
and I cannot tell you how many games end
with the following line a lot of people
uh instead of Knight G8 they play the
move Queen E7
they think oh let me pin the pawn white
plays Queen E2
uh reinforcing the threat of e takes F6
because now the king is no longer pin
the Knight is to drop back again we
start with Knight F3 and now tons of
people play the move D6 in this position
and D6 is a logical move on the surface
you're trying to get rid of the E5 pawn
and if he takes D6 who does the queen
trade favor well it favors the defending
side in this case it favors black but D6
loses on the spot who can tell me what
White's devastating winning move is here
Knight D5 ends the game
because the queen has to stay pegged to
the C7 Pawn so this gives up the queen
and after Queen d8 if you want to be
fancy take on C7 first this is the best
move
this is a very pretty move if Queen C7
Ed wins the queen and controls E7
and if King D7 then obviously you win
the rook and Black's position is in
shambles so lots of these little traps
in the Vienna uh that people fall into
because they're unaware of what to do
and so it is critical to play the move
D5 if you take away one thing from this
game don't forget to play D5 in the
Vienna if you're an E5 player
so F takes E5 Knight takes C4 is normal
and Knight F3 is an old school move I
don't didn't actually remember what to
do against it because almost everybody
nowadays plays Queen F3
and I want to show everybody a line that
equalizes against the Vienna pretty
easily and again I'm sorry Levy I I
myself have students who play the Vienna
with white but you know it's also
important to treat the other side fairly
the line that I always recommend here is
a relatively little-known move most
people they take on C3
remember that Queen H4 you might say
well didn't I just say that this move is
dangerous well it's not dangerous here
because white can just play G3 and
Knight takes G3 obviously doesn't work
because the Rook is defended by the
queen or you can just play Queen takes
you three so this is a dead end most
people play Knight takes C3 nothing
wrong with that move Knight takes E3 is
a totally legitimate line it's the main
line
it's the most popular move
and generally uh the cool kids play D
take C3 but this position can get very
dangerous for black really really
quickly a lot of people go into this
line thinking this just looks totally
fine for black and they end up losing
very quickly one particular uh
one particular course of action that is
often taken here is Bishop E7 Bishop F4
Castle's short already a mistake because
White Castle is long
and already the pressure on D5 has
become very very dangerous after Bishop
E6 there's the move C4 hopefully you
guys can see that this is this is no fun
for black so the line that I always
recommend after Queen F3 is Knight C6
this already sets a trap because you
might look at this and say wait a second
this blunders upon Knight takes C4
and you might think ah I've understood
Black's idea Black's idea is to play
Knight takes E5 and attack the queen and
when the queen moves then we're going to
recapture on e4 but that's wrong why is
that wrong why does this position favor
white who can tell me
Knight takes E5 is a blunder
remember that the Knight on E5 is itself
undefended so white can counter-attack
the queen
uh the Knight I apologize by moving the
queen
uh for example Queen G3
is a possibility but not Queen F4 not
Queen F4 because the Knight drops back
to a defended square and black is
chilling
so Queen G3 or queen C3 attacks the
Knight white keeps the extra piece
but the actual idea is to stick the
Knight on D4
to stick the Knight on D4
the queen has to move now you might say
well it's the same thing I can play
Queen D3 and attack the Knight but after
d takes E4 the queen protects the Knight
on D4 and white cannot take on e4
because Bishop F5 skewers the queen to
the C2 Pawn white is gonna end up losing
the Rook on A1 it's not the end of the
line I know there are some complications
after Queen takes B7 but you can throw
in the move Rook B8 uh to prevent a
bishop check on B5
Knight takes E2 check and now white is
busted white loses the rook and the game
is over
so it is very important for white to
know the move Bishop B5 here and now you
get a transition into an equal end game
Knight takes C3
uh B takes or D takes the line is the
same I think Levy gives DC3
now you throw in a check on H4
and you travel to E4 forcing the queen
trade and you get this end game and I've
analyzed this end game very carefully
and the position is equal neither side
is better so this is a very nice
practical line to know with black that's
basically all you have to know
and there are tricks in this end game as
well countless people end up playing 92
Bishop D7
and now the move Bishop F4
and after castles tons of people Castle
automatically this is a blunder who can
tell me why this is a tactical pattern
that I have talked about extensively on
the speedrun I've shown you plenty of
examples of title players missing this
type of idea
and you have to be
keenly aware of it the move is Knight
takes E5 yeah it's easy the move is
Knight takes C5
and uh
black wins upon because either you give
up the bishop or after Bishop D7 Knight
D7
black keeps the extra pun uh you might
recall that I had a game many years ago
where a very strong International master
blundered a almost identical pattern
and I often like to show this because
people don't realize how often
blunders happen in real life here it is
this is from 2010 one of my games
as you can see my opponent who just
played in title Tuesday by the way is GM
by now
is an Icelandic International master
and in this theoretical position he made
a new move
he thought for about 15 minutes and he
played Bishop G5
and of course he blundered a lot of you
will remember this not Knight takes E4
Knight takes E4 is wrong
why is it wrong because white plays
Knight takes C4 F takes E4 white throws
in Bishop E7 and then after F takes E4
everything is fine but the move is
actually Knight takes D5
same exact concept if white takes back
then you take the bishop the queen
defends the bishop and black is up a
pawn and if Bishop takes E7 then the
same Knight takes back on E7
this is what happened in the game or
sorry white played Bishop H6 in the game
admitting defeat I had a clear extra
pawn and I was able to win the game
back we go to the game in any case this
is the line that I recommend against the
Vienna for black it's this uh Knight C6
line
in this game our opponent played Knight
F3 and we made a relatively rare move
Bishop C5
uh inducing uh inducing D4 and now
swinging the bishop tb4 still a lot of
games in the database Bishop D2 Knight
D2 Queen D2 and Bishop E6 I think is a
very solid move
very solid move
five I see several games in the database
but after Bishop D3 as I explained
during the game I think the bishop trade
favors white I think the bishop trade
favors White
what about C5 instead of Knight takes C2
yes this is the main line according to
the database this is the most popular
move I honestly forgot about it
so you can investigate this on your own
I think C5 is probably totally
legitimate but we decided to play more
solidly nothing wrong with that Bishop
B6 A3 A3 Bishop E7 Bishop B2 I think
Bishop B2 might be a little bit
inaccurate if I were white I would
probably try to put the bishop on D3
which is a more active Square
uh but after Bishop B2 we castled and
now Knight D7 to prepare F6 why not
Bishop A5 well I explained this during
the game Bishop A5 allows B4 and the
bishop on B6 is imprisoned
by the pawns on B4 and D4 making it
harder to play C5 and again if white
plays B4 here we have the very powerful
move A5 threatening to capture the spawn
if white plays B5 then we are already
capable of playing C5 if we want it the
bottom line is that our Bishop is now in
control of this diagonal also the pawn
on A3 is very weak so who can tell me
what very typical positional move uh
should always be considered in this type
of situation this uh this also happens
in a lot of real Lopez openings yeah
it's the move A4
and as a follow-up question who can tell
me where the Knight on B8 often belongs
in these types of positions from where
is the Knight doing the most to put
pressure on White's weak Queen side
squares yeah B6 you will see this often
in Grandmaster again so black plays A4
to fix the pawn on a dark Square so that
the bishop pressures it Bishop B2 Knight
D7 you put the Knight on B6 for several
reasons protect A4 and threaten to jump
into C4 if White's Bishop is gone from
the diagonal and notice that White's
Rook is totally tied down to the pawn
so you see this very often also in real
Lopez positions
in the NC Marshall you have actually the
main line that goes exactly like that
so in the ANSI Marshall
you have this position
can you see the parallel there's a Pawn
on B5 so white has the move A4 and in
response to B4 uh in response to B4
uh A5 is one of White's most popular
lines and the bishop then repositions to
C4 and you often see the Knight moving
into B3 so lots of parallels to be found
in a lot of different openings I always
like to do that to help people
understand that these ideas are shared
between openings
so Bishop E2 castles castles Knight D7
Knight T1 F6 uh leading to a trade again
if White had refrained from trading on
E5 then we would have taken ourselves
then we would have played C6 in order to
protect D5 and we would have tucked the
queen away on C7 from where it attacks
the E5 pawn and in the long run the pawn
on E5 is a huge weakness it's a huge
weakness
so F6 ef6 Knight F6
uh why did my opponent play Knight T1
well as was revealed in the course of
the game it was to put the Knight on F2
and my guess is that later on he wanted
to bring the Knight to E5 uh what would
I have done after Knight G5 well I would
have played Bishop D7
and here our next move is going to be H6
white has a very Advanced very Advanced
move in this position that I was worried
a little bit about until I found a nice
response basically we're going to play
H6 on the next move and force the White
Knight away from G5 yeah Queen E3
worried me a little bit this is not an
easy move to play what is the point of
Queen E3 well the point of Queen E3 is
prophylaxis prophylaxis and chess is the
stopping of threats uh after H6 you want
to stick the Knight on E6 and force a
trade and now in this position notice
that all these light squares on the king
side are really weak so after Bishop D3
black is experiencing some trouble with
with these light squares
so what I had to find in this position
I think is the move Knight to G4
Knight to G4 is a cool move
so Rook takes f8 check Queen takes f8
you're attacking the Queen White has to
take we take back and I think here black
is totally fine we've got two Bishops
against two knights and 96 is no longer
dangerous we could just move the queen
because there's no longer a rook on f8
uh yeah Queen C8 is also fine
uh so so Knight G4 I think is a very
important resource once I saw an ig4 I
understood that this position is not
dangerous
by the way Queen D3 is another nasty
little move threatening Rook takes up
six but here we can just play G6 which
also creates a stronghold for our light
squared Bishop on F5 why Knight F6
instead of Rook F6 asks Chris OS well
Rook takes up six there's nothing
inherently wrong with Rook takes F6 it's
totally fine move but the reason it
looks weird to me is because it blocks
the bishop
The Rook could end up being vulnerable
like white can play 93 maybe Knight G4
later
I just don't see the point I don't
really see what the Rook is doing here
the bishop is kind of jailed and both of
these pieces are like hey I want the F6
square and the Knight needs it the most
because it's the jumping off point to E4
okay
uh one more question what about Knight
G5 instead of 91 this blunders a knight
because remember the queen protects G5
um does G6 weaken the dark squares asks
caprendo or do you not care because no
dark exactly exactly so to return to
that other line Knight G5 Bishop D7
Queen D3 G6 am I not worried about these
squares no because white doesn't have
the Machinery to take advantage of them
and even if white did I wouldn't be too
worried about it because our King is
nicely surrounded by all these pieces
that can serve as Defenders
does that make sense
so back to the game Knight F2 Bishop D6
to improve the bishop white does the
same so in this next stage we both
improve our pieces rookie Wonder key 8
C3 C6 and the fun really starts after
Bishop C2
this is where the fun starts white plays
the move Bishop C2 presumably I don't
know exactly why white made this move my
guess was that he was trying to vacate
the D3 Square for the Knight to bring
the Knight eventually to E5 but it's a
slow move
what would I have done instead here with
white I would have done one of two
things I would have either doubled my
Rooks on the e-file because it's really
the only open flywheel file is also open
but it's the main Center of action
and the second thing I would consider is
just to play Knight E5 put the knight in
the center
we would have dropped our Queen over to
C7 and then tried to smoke the night out
with Knight D7 but the position remains
approximately equal
um a lot of you are asking why didn't I
play C5 here well let me turn it back
around on you what does C5 do
what is the purp those of you who are
attempted to play C5 what exactly tempts
you about this move what does it
threaten what does it do what are you
trying to achieve
because the way I see it C5 no longer
achieves as much as it would have used
to achieve earlier because the pod on D4
is now perfectly protected
yeah but but White's not going to take
on C5 I will concede that in this
situation our Bishop is improved
although of course there is also a
drawback the D5 Pawn is isolated but
white does it have to take
and remember this right chess isn't
Checkers you don't have to capture
anything and you can never assume that
your opponent is just going to agree to
the trade just because a trade benefits
you white can just continue on with his
business yeah you can push C4 but big
whoop what does this accomplished this
just hems in the bishop
right and if you play cdcd who does this
favor well probably not black you know I
don't see why this favors black not to
mention that white can play Knight takes
D4 and blockade the iqp
um
now just because a lot of people do
automatically trade doesn't mean you can
make that assumption C6 Bishops you do
and Bishop F5
so Rook takes here Rook takes C8 I think
is already not a mistake
but I think already the situation
becomes
a little bit tense for white so takes
takes takes takes rookie one I think if
we would have traded this would have
been a draw this is just a dead draw
the problem is that Queen C2 which I was
tempted by initially fails to Queen E6
check
which is very very annoying
so for that reason we decided to spice
things up with Knight E4 and after Queen
D3 I think rookie 6 is the Cog that
makes the machine go without this rookie
6 move none of what we did subsequently
would have worked how did I find the
move Rook E6 and why is it such a good
move well I did some reverse engineering
and I realized that what is the the key
indicator of the health of Black's
position well it's whether we can
preserve the Knight on e4 and whether we
can always guarantee that in response to
Knight takes E4 we can recapture with
the pawn
the problem is that the rokan E8 is not
only undefended but anytime we move the
Knight white takes on E8 would check
that's a huge tactical asset so that's
the main thing I wanted to solve and we
solve it by putting the Rook on E6
because this kills two birds with one
stone we're also preparing to lift our
Rook to H6 how do I know that that's
good well I'm seeing that the bishop is
aiming at H2 and if the Knight on F3
moves away I realize that H2 was going
to be a serious weakness why was the
bishop pair asks human FTW suddenly not
an asset worth keeping yeah well I think
the situation changed because our light
squared Bishop kind of ended up being
pretty lame here and to me the
importance of trading off our opponent's
strongest piece outweighed the
importance of keeping the bishop air
alive
so it's just a more concrete
consideration so after rookie six white
plays the move C4
I was very attracted to the move Bishop
takes H2 check at first I thought it was
winning why did I think so well after
King takes H2 you get a really
interesting position
now at first you might say wait a second
the Knight is hanging but the queen is
saying we can't play in high takes F2
I thought we had the move Rook H6 check
and there is a beautiful detail here
originally I believed that King Juan
lost to Rook H1 as it turns out that was
the blunder that I made and I thought
that Knight H3 was forced who can find
the gorgeous winning sequence for black
here here black actually is winning and
this is what excited me initially
there's a beautiful idea here who can
spot it
if you're watching on YouTube pause the
video
yeah you can start with Queen F4 but
even more elegant start with Rook takes
H3 check
G takes H3 and now the critical check on
F4 if the king moves back to H1 Fork
time on F2
also notice the line doesn't end here
you have to make sure that the check
doesn't give anything but it doesn't
because we have the F7 Square no Forks
black is up a queen
and if King G1 then we Slide the queen
into G3 and it's Checkmate whichever way
the King goes of King F1 Queen F2 if
King H1 Knight F2 is made of course you
can also start with Queen F4
but the great thing about starting with
Rook H3 the reason it's actually better
than starting with Queen F4 is that
after King G1 there is another very
pretty tactic classic idea Rook H1 check
deflection Knight F2 picks up the queen
so for this reason why it has to play
games you want and now I thought Rook H1
still worked I forgot that the Knight
can just capture from a distance I
thought King H1 was forced and now
Knight takes F2 wins and so I had to
think on my feet and that's where I came
up with the move G5 which should be
perfectly logical to you if you've been
listening because what is the entry
point to White's King the entry point is
H2 or F2 and the move G4 satisfies both
of these qualities it you know weakens
the F2 square and it also weakens the H2
by forcing the Knight out of F3
rookie 2 G4 it is a tough move to make
because I can hear a lot of you saying
but doesn't it weaken the king side
um yes but white is almost out of pieces
right white is almost out of pieces it's
like
I don't know what to compare it to
um
but it's like
you know walking around it I I
previously people found this to be funny
compared it to like walking around in
your apartment you know with your
clothes off it's like oh my God you know
that's so uncivilized but if there's
nobody around like
who gives a [ __ ] you know like you can
spend three hours in the morning just
like you know walk around with no pants
on
um it's become very popular in the age
of Zoom same thing like aren't you
opening up your King well there's nobody
around to exploit it there's nobody
around to actually attack the king so so
G5 is a move you can make with a clean
conscience what should white have done I
don't know
I don't actually know what the best move
was according to the engine the only way
to equalize with CD CD Knight takes E4
girl and after de4 Queen C4
equalizes because you cannot take on F3
drop E6 with check
so Black's best move here is to move the
king out of the pin so that you can move
the rook and now white has to find
another accurate move D5 very difficult
move what is the purpose of D5 well if
the Rook moves to H6 then you drop the
E4 pawn and G4 is impossible so you have
to stay
oh my God the best line
okay rookie seven Knight D4 and the
Knight moves into E6 with a very unclear
position
with a very unclear position it's equal
according to the engine
uh because we have this monster battery
white has a monster Knight on E6 it's
zeros according to the engine but this
is very hard to find I mean just even
playing this move is really difficult
because your brain is like I can't take
on e4 I get forked and yet you have to
be concrete
so instead rookie 2 already is not
losing after G4 White had one more
chance to keep the balance this is still
equal
so white has to play CD
CD
and 95 only move only move
oh and this is so cool what is the
reason sorry sorry sorry sorry what is
the reason
uh that white has to play CD first what
is the reason the reason is that after
the immediate 95 black has Rook take C5
de5 and Bishop C5 with unstoppable
pressure on the Knight on F2
and the Difference Maker is that after
CDC d95 if you try to do the same thing
whereas Waldo the difference is that
Queen takes D5 check is devastating so
in that first line the pawn on D5 was
protected
and after 95 black has to resort to
Bishop E5 de Rook E5 but after 94 it
appears that white makes a draw even
though he's down a pawn
rookie 4 rookie 4 to E4 of course white
is worse
but according to the engine there's
enough counter play against Black's King
to make a draw so apparently G5 does
black bite in the you know what
I mean this is like this is tactical
detail that's very difficult Knight E5
is a hard move to play our opponent was
not sensing the danger and after Bishop
takes H2 check the game is over last key
point that I wanted to make there is a
beautiful idea I implied during the game
what was it the gorgeous idea was Rook
H6 King G1 and now who can find the
combination at this point you have to go
for the line if you give a check on H6
you have no choice
There's A really lovely idea
and I would call it the petrogen spaski
idea this is a theme
which you should recognize from a couple
of famous games if you've done your
puzzle solving
and I will show you exactly which game
this reminds me of the most
so petrogen spaski from their world
championship match in 1966 this position
occurred on the board white is down in
exchange and here Petrosian initiates a
gorgeous combination it starts well The
Rook takes F4 and Bishop E6 check black
has to block with a rook otherwise black
is checkmated Rook F7 Knight comes into
E4 stopping the black queen from
entering the game via G5
spassky tries Queen H4 now Knight takes
D6 Queen G5 check King H1 and Rook A7
this is the critical position a lot of
you should recognize this game this is
super famous Bishop F7 Rook F7
and now not Knight takes F7 which is
totally unconvincing due to Queen takes
E3 but Queen h8 check the final move of
the game very famous move and spaski
resigned because it forces the king onto
h8 and now you pick up both of these
pieces and you have an extra piece in
the end so this theme is surprisingly
common in a lot of different
combinations
and you can trace this theme Here Queen
takes F2 Rook takes F2 Rook H1
Force the king onto H1 and now do the
spasky thing uh sorry do the patrosion
thing and black is up upon and should be
winning here but it's very important
uh not to play to paint pictures but to
play to win games and G3 is so much
easier
G3 is so much easier yeah the whole line
is forced as you can see white literally
has only one response to each of these
things
but G3 is so much easier GF and Rook H6
just leads to Checkmate and I have to
prioritize you know objective value over
over Beauty
so yeah nothing white can do here the
best move according to the engine is
Queen H3 and it's made in seven so at
this point the game is over after G3
yeah you can't King takes G3 is illegal
the Knight defends the pot and that is
that 20 or 30 moves it was a nice game a
lot of stuff behind behind the scenes
so as I explained just as a takeaway
first of all if you're an E5 player
remember D5 in the Vienna
um remember that in boring positions you
want to try not to self-destruct you
want to try to make incremental
improving moves right F6 to undermine
the pawn improve improving the bishop
improving the queen The Rook solidifying
the pawn structure trading off your your
worst piece for White's best piece and
then understanding when an opportunity
has occurred which you can step on the
gas pedal this is where we stepped on
the gas pedal and hopefully my my the
rest of my moves were understandable
kudos to our opponent he played very
well it was not an easy game and I hope
you guys enjoyed thanks for hanging out
see you guys later tonight bye
foreign
[Music]